PHOTOBOMBS: CREEPY OR CUTE?
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
GAMES.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A PHOTO BOMB
PIC GONE VIRAL. FOR 250 POINTS
YOU HAVE TO TELL ME IF IT'S
PHOTOBOMBED BY SOMETHING
CREEPY OR SOMETHING CUTE. ALL
RIGHT?
SOMETIMES IT'S TOUGH TO TELL.
THIS FIRST ONE.
LOOK AT THIS YOUNG ARYAN PROM.
>> I THINK THE GIRL ON THE PHONE
IS LIKE, THESE PEOPLE ARE
SO [BEEP] WHITE, YOU HAE TO GET
ME THE HELL OUT OF HERE.
>> CREEPY OR CUTE, MATT BESSER
>> I'M GONNA SAY CREEPY 'CAUSE
THOSE TWO ARE ALREADY CREEPY
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
[LAUGHING]
>> THOSE GIRLS ARE NOW DEAD,
RIGHT?
>> NO, NO.
HE DIED AT THE LAST PROM. HE'S
ACTUALLY NOT PHYSICALLY THERE.
>> YEAH.
>> NEXT ONE.
>> THIS INTERRUPTED SEDUCTION.
>> OH.
>> NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF
THE @MIDNIGHT SYMBOL WHATEVER IS
THERE IS ENORMOUS.
DANIELLE.
>> I'M GONNA SAY IT'S CUTE.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE A CAT OR A
PUPPY DOG.
>> I'M BETTING ON A TYPE OF CAT.
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
>> HE DOES LOOK LIKE HE'S
ESCAPING THE VAGINA.
>> SHE FINALLY OPENED HER LEGS.
I'M OUT OF HERE.
>> NEXT ONE. THESE VACAY
THROWBACK TO THE WRIST
SCRUNCHY. SCRUNCHIES!
THIS -- THIS PHOTOGRAPH IS ONE
FANNY PACK AWAY FROM BEING
BEING THE ERA OF WHEN I WENT TO
COLLEGE.
YES. DANNAH.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH CUTE.
>> ALRIGHT.
LET'S FIND OUT.
>> A GIANT PENGUIN.
>> OH!
>> THAT'S CUTE.
THAT'S CUTE.
>> I THINK WHAT SHE'S DOING
TRYING TO PULL A DOG OUT OF HER
VAGINA.
HUNDRED POINTS FOR MATT.
OR, OR I'M JUST GETTING MY
SUNSCREEN.
THESE PANTS DON'T HAVE POCKETS,
WHAT AM I SUPPOSE TO DO.
LAST ONE, GROCERY STORE MOM.
GROCERY STORE MOM.
CREEPY OR CUTE?
YEAH, DANIELLE.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE CUTE
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, HE'S WATCHING
HER BREASTFEED. THAT'S CUTE.
>> NO, I THINK HE'S BREAST
FEEDING TOO.
>> NOW SEE, I WOULD'VE USED THE
INTERNET FORMULA OF THE THING IN
THE FOREGROUND IS ADORABLE, SO
THE THING IN THE BACKGROUND HAS
TO BE THE INVERSE, BUT I DON'T
KNOW, YOU SAID CUTE.
LET'S FIND OUT.
OH MY GOD, NICHOLAS CAGE.